És amikor rájönnek a a fizikai
dolgoknak, a megtapinthatóságnak a
kiteljesülési érményére, ami igazából
amit valában mindenki
üldöz egy élete során, akkor nekik ez
egy rövidebb folyamat lesz, mert ők ők
nem kell átmenjenek az algoritmusnak a
megírásán, az meg valakinek a
bemutatásán, hogy aztán később jöjjön a
a például az én szakmám esetében a a
legszebb rész az, amikor
egy tele osztályteremnek, egy 100
emberrel tele osztályteremnek, vagy vagy
publikus előadóteremnek valamit
elmondasz, és akkor az emberek a
tapsolás is szép, de a amikor befejeztél
egy gondolatot, és nincsen taps, és
amikor teljesen csend van, az az talán
az én szakmában a legérdekesebb, vagy a
leg
több dopamint felszabadítással jár járó
élmény.